I saw this story yesterday and I said to
Fritzi would you reach out to USC I'd
love to have Jake Olson back on the USC
long snapper he lost his sight at the
age of 12 but he was there at the USC
Pro day and he was bench pressing the
225 that they always have you bench he
did 17 reps and then I realized he was
raising money to fight this rare cancer
that took his eyesight Jake good to have
you back on how did it feel yesterday
hey and thanks for having me again man
so awesome awesome you know what it's
amazing how your expectations change I
see you if you said I was got 17 to 25 I
would have been very happy but I know I
was hoping to get into 20 so sweet but
but you know it's all right give me a
few more months I guess
okay explain how you're raising money
for this disease they took your I sign
so yep so basically my freshman year r1
the uplifting athletes awards for the
National Football Club and they always
do a fundraiser through pleasure with
their recipients every year or you know
graduating and doing the bench press
Freeza combine other pro days and see
Alex announcing support rare diseases so
they're like you know would you be
willing to do a fundraiser I said yes
but anyway we can really specify it to
retinoblastoma just because obviously
you know I wanted to help you know go
look towards a college as much as I
could and so they under the kind of
bylaws they couldn't get that specific
with this so I kind of search for
something else I could I could do with
it that was more specific and sure
enough I talked to some researchers that
were around you know when I was going
through it all and at the time 10 years
ago they were developing this device
that honestly if it was ready 10 years
ago probably would have saved my sight
so unfortunately wasn't ready then but
it was it is ready now actually last
year they treated kind of experimental
II with it to kids up in Toronto to
three-year-olds that were in my position
no when I left exhausted all the
treatment options they tried this thing
and the kids are totally cured
so this this new device it's like aloe
chemo plaque non-invasive chemo that
just directly goes to the tumors in the
eye kind of sits right outside on the
other and basically if it becomes a
standard for a retinal blastoma to treat
it and I mean the reality is no kid
really would ever have to lose right
eyesight to the cancer again which would
just be absolutely amazing how can
people get involved in this is there a
website that they can go and donate yeah
so my campaign is open to April 1st so
you know you can make a pledge per rep
and you know I did 70 so you could do
that way just make a donation but it's
it's the website should pledge it like
you're pledging something quite scarce
org slash Jake as well do you remember
your last year last site like what what
you saw before you went under yeah I
mean you know it was you know I mean one
of the hardest moments was when I was
obviously that day in the hospital and
all the nurses and doctors obviously
maybe at that point from you know being
in and out of the hospital for 12 years
and so you know we were all crying just
because again I mean it was real
personal for everyone I remember like
the nurse she had the IV in me or
whatever and she I mean I remember she
telling me basically you know just tell
me when you're ready you know you know
give you the propofol you know put you
out but you know at that moments like I
it was the hardest thing cuz I'm like
you know what am I supposed to say I'm
ready you know it wasn't necessarily
it's like okay I know I'm good and and I
was ready at age 12 for something like
that let alone any age ya know I mean
I've never seen my parents say citizens
just anglish in their faces and it was
was a sad moment but but the crazy thing
is I mean I remember do remember waking
up from that surgery I'm sure I mean I
was I was definitely had some drugs in
my system but but I do remember just
kind of being a burden off my off my
shoulder and back in the sense that you
know I really wasn't leading up to the
surgery with so much of this anxiety of
me losing my sight and never being OC
again that once that kind of reality set
in or after I woke up kind of like okay
you know this is
this is my new I live with a so you know
let's start you know again not to be
cliche but fighting on you know and keep
keep moving forward and not you know
forfeiting my life to my circumstances
yeah I just can't imagine you're 12
you're going to the hospital you know
that they're gonna put you under you're
gonna wake up and you're not going to be
able to see and you're looking at your
parents but from your parents
perspective you know this is the last
time you see them I mean I just I can't
process how that had to be so difficult
for them like you would kind of alright
I understand it this is what it is
there'll be a relief on the other end
but mom and dad I just can't imagine how
yeah how much pain to film yonk then I
can't either and I really don't want you
I mean that's just like another side of
it a children but I mean it's like I I
for anyone who doesn't know that yeah
that's another side do with that to be
honest I they're they're very strong
individuals and you know I try to you
know do things in my life that makes
them proud and it you know kind of gives
them another another life with me that
you know besides the first 12 years that
there could be proud and happy with and
I mean obviously they're proud and happy
with me throughout all those years but
I'm just saying you know you know I
definitely want to imagine it like
you're saying yeah do you play jokes on
people with your sight of course it's
pretty funny you know we always had fun
out there and the big conspiracy is
actually Dan is that I'm not blind
that's the conspiracy it goes around a
football team and some other people I
know I know every time I do something on
social media there's always people like
comment as well so what you want Dan
maybe maybe I'm not maybe I'm thinking
this whole thing just Felicity it should
be honest II am Patrick Joey no yeah
yeah I probably wouldn't have you on if
you had your site you were a long
snapper Jake just letting you know yeah
what are you doing after graduation oh
you know I'm gonna obviously continue to
speak you know I signed with UTA here in
LA so you know gonna be doing some cool
things and I know we have a campaign
without a shoulder
coming up that can be pretty cool
revolving the draft and I'm going to I
started a company actually with my
manager called engage is that let's
engage colleges on online kind of
digital booking platform that we're
really excited about it's kind of
picking up some steam and then just
getting back to playing competitive golf
you know I want just want to see how far
I could take you know golf cart was my
first for that so she had to go and
blind that is something I really wanted
to make sure I could see be become the
best girlfriend I know I can you had a
hole-in-one hooked up you know I've
never had a hole-in-one and it really
upsets me but but it's coming it's
coming
I I will not die without having a
hole-in-one
yeah but you know what knowing your
friends they would probably lied to you
and say you had one you know it's one of
those things do that like my dad always
worries about because if he has a hole
one like you know the etiquettes you
know you don't approach the green now
the person who's go up and you know
verify it so he's like I'm gonna have to
like call out you to you know lead you
to the stick without me going up there
the worst eye witness out there well
good luck Jake it's great to hear about
what you're doing and hear from you
again and I know you'll be successful
because you already are so thanks again
for joining us all right thank you guys
that's Jake Olson the blind long snapper
from USC ESPN did a nice little feature
on him earlier this year we were able to
have him on after he got into the game
last year so graduating in May so pretty
good stuff Dan Patrick show brought to
you by mercedes-amg be prepared for
whatever comes your way the all-new GT
4-door coupe because life is a race
visit your local dealership for a test
drive today and if you missed any of the
interviews on this program the Mercedes
AMG man-cave go to the Dan Patrick show
app where you can watch and listen from
inside the Mercedes AMG mancave Mercedes
AMG driving performance yeah it's a good
story there I just you know when you're
a parent venit these stories affect you
differently that if your child and
you're taking your child he's 12
and you're
taking him to the hospital and you know
when he leaves the hospital he probably
will never see again I just can't
imagine what the parents because you're
helpless like Jake has to get in his
head
I got a fight now now the fight begins
and you know III don't want your
sympathy I got to do this I got to
survive I got to live my life but as
parents you're just watching and there's
so many times that you go in when your
child is in surgery sick and you can't
do anything about it
and if you've ever been in there and you
know those moments when all of a sudden
there's something serious with your
child they broken a leg or an arm you
know I've gone through those visits and
you can't you can't do anything about it
you could just be there and then you
realize if you've instilled that
toughness as Jake his parents did a
wonderful job you can tell that but just
to be there knowing that your child when
he closes his eyes when they put him
under and he wakes up he may open his
eyes but he's not seeing you ever again
and then you start to look at all the
things that'll happen in your life you
know when he gets married when you have
your first child and for him to be able
to feel the child hold the child but not
see the child and those are all the
things that went through my mind when I
first heard about Jake and it's not just
Jake but his story was brought to our
attention there's so many other people
who don't have the means didn't get to
go to USC didn't get to get on national
TV you know but he wants to give back
raising awareness for this disease that
took his eyesight so good for him for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you